thank you to Andy and Dennis for
inviting us over here we are very very
excited
I'm Surratt mucukunda and I have a
colleague here Vegeta Mannion we're
going to talk about MIPS open and what
it is all about I'm going to provide
overview of what it is the licensing and
what are the different components and I
have maajid will go into detail on the
architecture side of things so we are
very very excited and the reason is
obvious because it all started here and
I'm sure you all know the gentleman in
the picture and it's none other than he
needs no introduction dr. Hennessey so
it all started in 1981 along with you
know his fellow scientists you know it
all started in this own campus of
Stanford campus so what happened from
then to now the project that started in
1981 that this is 2019 it has gone
through many releases as you can see
from mips32 / 64 release 1 through
release 6 so that's the latest
architecture that we have and over the
course of time what we have done is we
have added many instructions extensions
in features to enhance the the
architecture that not only can satisfy
the requirements for the low embedded
devices but also the high end AI systems
and different market segments that that
needs the embedded processors now with
that instruction this is a kind of
timeline so this was we announced when I
say we now lips as part of wave
computing so we announced initiative or
the intent in December
18 and then we collaborated with
something called open source foundation
or purple foundation and that's where we
form double member committee called webs
open Advisory Committee and then in
March of 28 March 28 that is less than a
month we actually made all these
components available for the community -
you know download and actually work on
the stuff real time with that said one
of the key components the micro active
embedded course that's still in the you
know you're testing it it's in the last
phases that we released pretty soon so
that's going to happen in me so the key
components are there are four components
as you can see it's a complete package
you have the architecture then you have
the course so the the course are built
using that architecture the fpga system
fpga system is more for training
evaluation and teaching purposes and
then you have the tools it's a full
fledge ide Eclipse IDE along that you
know that's Linux and and all the other
software that is not only provided by
wave or MIPS but also from the ecosystem
third-party partners so as I said this
is available for download from EPS open
comm you can just go directly to MEPs
open calm and download any of those
packages and there are like you know
four packages as I said and the open
course is something that's going to
release very soon so what does the mips
open architecture download package
includes so it includes the the latest
r6 the release 6:32
and 64-bit versions and the Cindy this
is used actually popularly used in
multiple applications the DSP extensions
for multimedia applications voice video
and then you have multi-threading
multi-threading is a very unique feature
for our MIPS that was introduced way
back and we continue to maintain that
and enhance that and and what he is
going to talk about the applications
where actually multi-threading can be
used for example the Mortons LTE 5gn and
so on and then we have the lips and see
you the micro Maps for code compression
and the virtualization virtualization is
another key feature that is available in
the in the MIPS instruction set and
architecture for isolation of the
secured applications versus the non
secure the mips open course again this
is something you know it's a complete
package it's a production ready package
what this means is it has shipped in
millions of devices in the low invented
you know the devices microcontroller
devices and the package will include the
actual very large source RTL code so
anybody can take the score and can do
their own you know system on chip right
away it also includes the configuration
tools and UDI is the user-defined
instruction which is if you want to add
your own instructions you have the
flexibility to do so through UDI and we
provide enough documentation and
examples for you to take that and then
do a full fledge you know system on chip
that will not only have the MIPS
instructions but also you can enhance
with with your own instructions then
there is a complete verification trust
suite and
and test bench included in that as I
said there is a whole lot of
documentation for you to you know with
examples so that it'll help expedite the
process and most importantly we have
something called the certification
process certification process this
really helps to ensure the compatibility
with the MIPS instruction set and and
the course the way we have developed so
you can take this you know core and do
your own implementation and send the
test results to maps so we what we will
do is we will ensure the compounded
compatibility will verify that and give
you a certificate what this really means
is you will now have access to MIPS open
certified trademark tools as I said it
includes you know the tools download
package includes a full-fledged IDE with
a claim and we are adding more features
more hardware boards and probes and all
of that and then it's also support
synapse Linux and in the compilers so
all of these tools are not only
available from wave in MIPS but also you
know there are a lot of third-party
tools that are available for MIPS
the FPGA package is really for you know
evaluation purposes and for teaching
it's a very good tool there we have you
know this is again based on the micro
active of micro processor core but this
is a non production core it's a it's a
fixed configuration core that's part of
the package and there are multiple labs
that are available that you can go
through and also an example system on
chip design so little bit to give you an
idea of what the license is all about
so this is a open use I'll open use
license what this really means is it's
you don't have to pay any license fee
it's it's royalty-free
and it's a worldwide license you can
develop the MIPS open-architecture
compliant core so using the instruction
set whether it is 32-bit 64-bit
multi-threading you know DSP or all of
those features you can develop your own
you know core compliant core and then
you can even supplies and set to the
semi vendors and who can actually then
prioritize it so but there are only a
few you know you you may not you know
develop the the course or release the
course that are not lips open certified
the reason for that is very simple we
want to avoid any fragmentation out
there you want to make sure that it is
compliant with the lips instruction and
and so once you have the soap and
certified you can sub license it to the
vendors and you cannot mix and match the
licenses which means that the the lips
open use you have to strictly abide by
the license and the reason for that is
we have you know licenses for some that
are meant for you know non MIPS open
course that are still available so we're
not we don't want to contaminate the two
licenses so it's it's a strictly follow
the you know the nips open license so
this is kind of you know it summarizes
so if you see on the left we have you
know lips open FPGA the package that is
available for training teaching and
evaluation purposes
it's a full-fledged package it includes
as I said commercial
a core that is non production core that
you can use and you know use it for
evaluation purposes then you can take
the architecture and develop Ian or your
own core and there are tools available
from us from partners then we have a
certification process in place so you
can take you can utilize that and make
sure that it is compliant with the lips
architecture then once you have done
that you can you can also add your own
customer IP third-party IP and then do
associate design and then you can you
can literally you know anybody can sell
or licensed architect the core to the
semiconductors so at high level the
features snips is open use license and
it includes all the components so the
latest r6 architecture the my craft of
course the tools and the fpga system we
provide the certification services and
that that includes you know the
verification and certification and
compliance of the webstore collector and
then we also make available the the
right and license under our r6
architecture of the patents and the lips
certified trademark logo and as i said
it is a complete comprehensive package
the benefits it's a unified approach so
that there is no fragmentation same
tools can be used across the
architecture course that will be
developed by the core developers and so
the same tools software and you also
have flexibility to add your own
instructions through UDI it's it's a
proven architecture it's shipped in
billions of devices and multiple
products from wired wireless modems you
know automata motive and
multiple market segments there is a
established ecosystem that is available
today so you can get started right away
it's a mature technology started at 1981
so it's like you know 30-plus years of
legacy with that I'll pass it on to my
colleague Thank You Suraj thank you for
inviting us I'm taking I'm covering the
second part of the presentation which is
focus more on the extensions that are
part of the MIPS that we offer most
recently as part of our six and some use
cases but before I start I wanted to
mention a few words about why EPS open I
think in addition to what Suraj
mentioned number one is that people ask
that there are other open Isis out there
and you know I know you guys coming a
little bit late and I look at this you
know we started about six months ago
make the announcement and are now
introduced the capability and when you
look at it for the past six months is
effectively almost about twenty years
worth of innovation that's been
compacted into six months and if you go
to our website or actually it's open
website you're going to see for yourself
that the amount of technology and
innovation that is available for you to
design your next generation server high
performance computing IOT gateway
routers for AI platform is there ahead
of almost any other open source or
capability that's out there so you can
start immediately today implementing
your own solution at no cost who have
cost from anybody else you know millions
of dollars in upfront and millions of
dollars as a royalty and extreme that
has a look you would pay so all of that
is gone and now become available
for anyone to use and the depth and the
breadth of the technology and collateral
and information that's available as part
of MIPS Oakland is much much ahead of
anything else that's out there so I am
actually at the wave I started at
imagination sometime back in that MIPS
but my actual engagement with MIPS goes
back roughly more than 25 years ago when
I started at LSI logic with providing
the core to like self PlayStation Sony
Playstation one and two and then working
with likes of major telecom and telecom
companies of the time comm that the
design their products around using MIPS
as a means of getting to market faster
caveum is public of course one of the
major reasons that the caveum became
successful with their technology was
utilization of what's available as
what's called UDI user-defined
instructions which means that you can
actually say that I can take a few
instructions and a compact them into one
instruction that does maybe a layer 3
networking processing or a search
processing as a result I can come up
with custom instruction and map that to
my assembler compiler and now I get a
boost and that boost people claim when
you're from 3 to 10 X boost over
standard processors so the UDI has been
used with our lot of work and
architectural licensing customers to
implement unique features in software
they can boost performance I will talk
about some of that so I'm going to talk
about what
Siraj mentioned as part of MIPS open we
are actually enabling anyone to develop
their own core on their own meaning that
you can come to MIT's open download
today and start design your core
sometimes it takes
months sometimes it takes years and the
amount of effort that requires that if
you're going after an IOT less complex
to a high-performance computing it takes
a lot more effort but in order to really
help them the industry we also in
addition to opening up the icer
they're also enabling a few of our cores
to be available at no cost this course
would cost a lot of money if you would
have come to us a year ago no there is
no licensing fee or royalty and we those
cores are referred to as micro active
cores that's the first line and micro
active core is heavily used in many of
the IOT applications embedded and
functional safety and other areas and
then you're making those available so
you can actually start the design today
and actually build your product based on
a processor and go to market without
having to worry about paying any any
dollars behind it and also the core is
validated I don't know Siraj mentioned
today we are shipping more than a
billion devices that are based on MIPS
core you're in tens of billions of
dollars of there are tens of billions of
units of course
so it's proven and you have track record
so there's no concerns about using the
core and all the features are available
for you to use as as Suraj mentioned
some of the unique values that customers
of MIPS continue to use our solution
when you look at that or websites and
search for MIPS is multi-threading we
have a good presence in the automotive
space we have a good presence on 5g and
networking data center acceleration and
multi-threading is one of the key
features that differentiates MIPS for a
lot of these embedded applications and
we'll talk about the how why we also
have Hardware backed virtualization if
you're trying to run let's say
multi-tenant environments
it used to be only for a data center
obviously multi-tenant applications find
their ways into the embedded space so
virtualization is one way to do it but
the add hardware support for that as a
result it improves the performance of
the platform we'll talk about that sim
the SIMD which is single instruction
multiple data is also another capability
for doing that say if you're doing some
AI functions DSP functions
floating-point functions and if you're
looking for dot products Cindy is is
actually very efficient engine that is
bolt on to the core so allows you to
enhance your compute power and improve
the compute power enormous Lee actually
and I will talk about some use cases so
this first slide is actually talking
about the open use core that'll be I
talked about micro active micro active
is a core that is developed is a 32-bit
based on mips32 it's a five stage
pipeline architecture unlike its
competitors it actually has a lot more
registers that you can have freedom of
managing your application more
effectively interrupt latencies are
quite fast for a lot of these
applications because we have what we
call shadow registers for example that
you can shadow application so if an
interrupt comes we can actually almost
instantly jump to in trouble that having
to do a lot of push and pop from stack
those are very helpful it provides a DSP
ASE application specific extension and I
think it brings the best of this class
as far as the core mark or dim apps and
for this class you know you can easily
get to tree and have core mark or 1.7
dinners from megahertz the device
besides the shadow register that I
mentioned it's a risk risk engine so
it's a single cycle per instruction
simple memory addressing mode
but it also has what I refer to as the
UDI
if you can look at this party so UDI is
as I mentioned use that define
instruction so we're going to do a lot
more work with MIPS open community to
for example define maybe a is extensions
or other extensions that you would find
and create a capability around the UDI
to enhance your application so UDI is
means to expand the instruction but
maintain uniformity on the operating
systems and compilers and assemblers
this core is going to be available for
download within a matter of days or
weeks and you can check the mips open
website for for that information there
are two different flavors of the core
one is the U P one is MP that allows you
to be able to run if you're running
Linux you can run Linux if you don't
need to run to Linux you want the
complexity you can actually use a
simpler form of the MMU to manage your
artists or bare metal applications very
popular core as far as performance it
clearly beats the competition of the
similar core it's in this class when you
compare to PPA
performance power area at 40% and
performance and in case of DSP
applications you get 90% boost so next
our first item I was going to actually
cover is you know the virtualization as
I mentioned and and multi-threading so
you know if you guys are familiar with
virtualization is the intent of virtual
virtualizing is CPU is in this diagram
is ability to create contexts that you
can separate and this can be done purely
and software meaning that you get an
interrupt and read columns in the bottom
or privileged state and you get those
interrupts you
can actually switch your application
from one to the next that time tt-time
can be changed based on the tick of your
desired application so you cannot in
this case for example we have four
tenants or for clients or for guests
that are running instead so since that
the intervals are pretty small from
application perspective you don't notice
that you're actually switching but
effectively you're switching from one
application to the next application and
the there is what's called a hypervisor
that you see the type the function of
the hypervisor is to switch these
contexts so when it's been you only
looking at software mechanism in doing
that what happens is that there is a lot
of overhead because if you're running in
one client running let's say Linux Derek
line is running Windows then you have to
do a lot of flushing and cleaning up of
the CPU and its environment from Linux
and setting up their windows and I'm
bringing up the windows and run so the
overhead is quite significant and some
of that has to do with flushing the cash
registers and so forth so what we have
done is that we have added hardware
support for some of those so the
overhead associated with these
switchovers are minimized and allows you
to do context switching easily at almost
10x of what a software version would do
so this is available so if you're not
trying to say I'm going to develop the
next generation server that needs to
have support for multi tenants we can
actually take advantage of the
virtualization to be able to do that or
for that matter I have a access point a
router a gateway that I will have a
client application where says my home
application maybe is you know maybe a
verizon application or wants to allow as
someone else to program so now you can
access create separation so OS one can
be the home product and that was - can
be a guest product and that's actually
becoming quite critical in almost every
Emma
the application whether that's an
automotive or gateway or router so
ability to use context switch but then
at the same time you want to make sure
it's secure and safe and now we will
talk about how you can actually sure
that these isolated environments are
protected because we wanted a don't want
contamination you don't want to cross
contamination of one operating system to
the other one or is dropping or
monitoring so the hardware actually
creates a create this clear separation
that separation protects one operating
system from the other one so that's part
of what the hardware virtualization
offers separately you have simultaneous
multithreading in the case of
simultaneous multithreading it kind of
looks the same but in this situation we
have different course you can have let's
say four threads you can two threads or
more or but in the context of
multi-threading you're actually doing
context switching at the clock rate so
effectively you could have four
operating systems concurrently run
putting a simple in a simple terms if
time is hundred percent in this case
each operating system gets 25 percent
not necessarily we'll talk about that
but there's benefit into multi-threading
as well we'll talk about what is the
benefits now someone can actually take
the virtualization technology and
multi-threading and combine the two now
you can actually benefit from
concurrency while you're actually for
ensuring isolation in some some some
situations so there is a lot you could
do at this point and many many of our
customers take advantage of these type
of situations which we'll talk again
later
so in the case of multi-threading that I
mentioned where you have concurrency
basically what what it allows you to do
because you're taking a CPU resources
and multi-threading it at the hardware
level not a software there's a very
different and software threads it's
actually Hardware threads and the
harbour threads allow you to actually
get a boost and we have seen ourselves
in our lab and doing a lot of benchmarks
as much as 60% instruction per clock
boost what does that really mean why is
that actually it doesn't solve every
problem in the world when it comes to
software what it solves is that if
you're trying to reach out to an i/o
generally in the case of a hardware when
you're reaching out to i/o weather is
Ethernet or USB or PCI Express and try
to read it's in the order of 10 cycles
to hundreds of cycles depending on how
far the i/o is from the CPU and what the
latencies that are there for a
round-trip delay if I want to read
something from the i/o so for the time
that you're waiting for i/o you more or
less become idle because you have to
wait for results with multi-threading
what happens is that you actually
replicate the instruction flow in such a
way that you can actually have second
independent flow that can take advantage
of the resources of the CPU so you don't
really make sure that you utilization of
those resources are improved so as a
result if you have two threads running
one sir can be waiting and if it's
waiting you're actually in that the Hart
Hardware allows the other thread to
start utilizing the resources and as a
result we get a higher boost in running
your CPU so we have seen as as many as
60% we have customers that did their own
architectural license and so they you
know what I have a networking
application I want to do heavy
distributed workload processing I want
to create my own 12 threads I put 12
threads you use same resources because
in that for example an Ethernet
environment
I gotta go after 12 ports and each one
will take time so I can have a better
utilization while I'm waiting I can't
use my utilization better in that
context I can given 200 percent
improvement in Portales ation when you
compare it to a single-threaded
environment so you get higher throughput
put that much less energy into it if you
actually go to the website and search
for let's say MIPS and MediaTek one of
the folks that are doing 5g technology
or 4G the clearly endorsed the fact that
multi-threading in this context allowed
them to keep the same envelope of power
while improving the throughput so now
you get a lot more while you're
maintaining the same so multi-threading
is very effective for many applications
out there that are that can be taken
advantage of a distributed workload
processing in addition when you have
multiple threads you can say you know
what I'm gonna take thread zero and
assign it to interrupts not if you
remember from the diagram before where
you had four of them running
if thread zero was assigned to
interrupts you can actually Park it and
make it wait for interrupts so the
moment Interop happens what happens in a
single threaded environment you have to
push everything on a stack there is a
lot going on before you can even service
the ISR the service TSR could be
hundreds of clocks sometimes thousands
of clocks that takes to go from one
context that's in this case an ayah
surah and nmi that comes in so you can
avoid that you can actually say my
highest critical application our events
that I need to respond to it would sign
it to thread zero when the interrupt
happens our jump and that jump is
literally instant so now you can say
that okay now what if I'm an automotive
every clock cycle counts for autonomous
vehicle I cannot afford waiting when I
see an interrupt comes and says
turn left so those are some of the
critical elements that attracts our
customers saying yes I'm gonna use
multi-threading and I'm gonna use it in
such a way that I can use these treads
for getting response times faster to my
application so clearly what we call you
know call zero or low overhead for
interruptus ponds but there is a 5g
application it's autonomous vehicle but
there is other applications that require
instant response to an event and we kind
of kind of starting to see a lot of
those but there's a drone going on and I
have to look at something that's
obstruction or some other you know the
response don't have to be much less and
sometimes measured in today is measured
in microseconds and when expecting that
actually starts to drop to nanoseconds
or response time as we need to get these
applications running then responding
quickly the other thing is of course you
can you can actually use multi-threading
as I said the four threads let's say in
this application I shown so you can
actually from a sip from a Linux
perspective you sees four CPUs so
literally is like a four core so Linux
seconds of course you can catch is the
specific how many cores you see from
Linux and in case of multi-threading in
this particular use case you can say I'm
gonna run an SMP Linux how many cores do
you have for all of a sudden you
actually see a four core where it's
actually a single core but has four
Hardware threads or you can say I have
four distinct different applications as
I mentioned and I can run a NP
application a symmetric multiprocessing
and I see four CPUs for four distinct
separated applic you know stream of
applicant instructions so it could be
completely different one could be our
task on the Linux one would be control
the more could be interrupt
CUDA matter so multi-threading provides
a lot of different ways to benefit from
improving
throughput utilization of of your
instruction and as a result you can
either get Headroom or law real power
and you actually get more faster
response time
all right so this is trying to explain
for example the example that I've shown
threat 1 to threat for are actually four
distinct instruction flows it's like you
know you know one thread one could be a
linux threat - could be an artist threat
three could be a better bare metal and
four could be and is are completely
coming from different part of the memory
they can be booted separately
independently but what happens that all
four of them are running through the
same and as you can see they can
actually utilize the resources and T the
execution queue and the pipeline and in
actually the execution unit can be not
shared
so if thread 1 is waiting for response
thread 3 - and and other threats
actually can actually utilize those
resources and that's how you get what's
called instruction per clock higher when
you look at a single threaded
application where there is anybody Intel
arm maps PRP see spark and you look at
those processors in a typical
application an IPC or instruction per
clock and I'm just drawing a number but
generally is under 1 meaning that
because I have to wait for a response
from you now have a cache cache miss so
I gotta you know reload it takes time
start to wait those two weights
transistor translate to stalls
and translate to taking your instruction
per clock lower than one sometimes the
average in point seven point eight in
this situation as I mentioned you get
sixty percent boost so you can actually
get to 1.6 1.7 depends how many threads
you're running so depending on the
workload you can actually get a lot of
efficiency out of multi-threading and
people that understand it can take
advantage of it and you've seen this
heavily used in a storage application
networking application most recently if
you look at web and Google us
you'll find this in automotive space
you'll find us in modem space
that allows you to get higher higher
throughput maintaining your power
envelope same so again as I may be
talked anytime that up you know you need
to do parallel processing what is
parallel processing distributed workload
is one example then you have multiple
OSS running or single OS in s SMP
environment when you have multiple
workers when you have function sensitive
to context switching between tasks when
you want deterministic behavior that's
another one right automotive when I need
to turn left at autonomous car I don't
want to wait I want to make sure that I
jump into that event respond to it
instantly so there are many ways of
doing it this way you get a lot more
efficiency because if I if the decision
to turn left in a car is based on thread
zero would instantly respond if that
thread is a software trade sitting on in
a major flow instruction flow yeah child
you actually have to do a lot of clean
up before you can service the ISR or nmi
so it that translates to because I have
another nm is happening how do I respond
to so you get to a situation where you
have a variable length response time so
deterministic behavior is not guaranteed
so as I mentioned a - networking VoIP
and other other areas this is quite
useful so I'm going from multi-threading
to virtualization now it's still very
different there are different concepts
on the left side is a non-virtual
virtualized environment you have a Linux
you know a Linux kernel you've got a
user space and the kernel is privileged
all your drivers are the kernel level
managing resources
memory is managed through the kernel so
in the case of left you have a TLB
traditional TLB MMU they can control
under control of the kernel level that
protects the memory allocates memory
releases memory and so forth the user is
limited but in this situation if you
want to have multiple environment
running then you actually have to manage
they use the new user if the user is and
Linux and you want to have two Linux
running it becomes quite challenging on
the left side because now you have to
manage the TLB ease and I'm using caches
and lots and lots of resources to
protect them or isolate them with the
hardware virtualization capability which
is some some of the cable that we are
actually providing through mips open now
you're able to actually have from the
right side of the diagram four levels
you got the root level if you remember
from that diagram that the root was at
the bottom the root level here is the
privileged state most highest privilege
state of the CPU and then you can have
guests on top the guests are the tenants
or the virtual machines this guests are
intended to be the no different than the
gal at this configuration on the left so
literally if the under on the left side
you were done running a Linux that exact
environment can be just dropped into the
right environment and it will just run
you don't have to really make any
changes so from Linux perspective it
doesn't know it's virtualized but there
is Hardware element that actually
creates that separation so you can take
the same exact Linux and copy twice drop
it there and they wouldn't even know
that there are two copies of Linux
running
that's nervously normally to standard
trend with the virtualization and the
hypervisors but in this case there are
Hardware mechanism that enforces those
isolations and doesn't require this
to do a lot of cleanup once you're doing
a context switch from one Linux to the
next when you power up generally
actually actually all the time in this
in this fashion you would normally boot
up to the root context now you're
actually coming to the root context
which is the most privileged state if
there was any type of root of current
the root of them root of trust or in
type of secure boot you want to make
sure that the root context is
authenticated validated but once you get
to the root kernel and you're starting
to establish and initializing the entire
system then you can decide ok I want to
bring first guest up I'm being
second-guessed stuff and the
architecture that is available from its
open allows to handle up to 255 guests
in the embedded space we haven't really
seen that many guests but let's say if
you want to develop a NIC that needs to
handle a server a space that requires
128 clients you can actually enforce in
a CPU 124 environments that can be
completely isolated and protected from
each other so what's called a guest ID
as you see on the diagram is is an 8-bit
value what we have done at MIPS we use
three bits four bits five bits so far
that allows us to get up to seven of
course
fifteen or thirty one environments that
can be isolated from each other and
customers use them in that fashion have
one assigned to security have one
assigned to you know application
operating system or arthas and so forth
so the guest ID is a mechanism to
enforce the isolation and guest ID is
under control the root so there is no
possible or easy way or possible way
that the guests can actually manipulate
or alter the state of the root because
for one the registers that are in
control of the root are not visible to
the guests
however the guest registers are visible
to the
so what is the privilege they can see
everything but every guest only sees its
own resources so as a result you can
create environments that are fully I was
a protected or separated or isolated
it's not necessarily secured Security's
different discussion but they're clearly
and enforced you can enforce policies to
separate these these environments but
they get you want to call them guest
tenants or virtual machines this is
another way of looking at it may be
easier to see but the root context as I
mentioned is a privileged state you can
actually have isolated guest context
there are different means as that's
shown here when reset happens you are
actually start at the root context root
kernel and now you can initialize the
system and and enable different guests
but if the mechanisms to actually
request for service from the from the
root context and those mechanisms are
also displayed here where you can
actually either for example you have a
USB call or PCI or Ethernet you can
dedicate the i/o that in that case and
Ethernet port and to guest number one
and ether number even at port 2 goes to
guest number two so you can actually
also program that interrupts are
directly handled to there a specific
guest and only handled by that guest but
if you want to share resources you can
say no what I just don't trust any other
guests I'm gonna put all my resources in
the root context and actually make those
requests through the root so there are
mechanisms to actually communicate
between the guest and the root looking
for services looking for memory
allocation or memory and other other
means so it is intended to make sure
that the root context has full control
and can allow a guest to have also a
control but the kiss cannot really
influence the route and you can always
go to the root context and manage your
entire system in that environment so you
could clearly create environments that
can also be secured in this case again
we're showing that as you know multiple
OS is running route can be a secure
hypervisor
it can be so you could actually design
your system that saying that I want to
make sure my route context is secure as
a result I can count on it it can be a
chain of trust for my route of trust so
in that situation as you're booting up
you have authentication mechanism it
comes up authenticates your kernel root
root root kernel and then brings it up
at that point is a chain of trust they
can actually start further
authenticating the rest of the system so
root can't actually be a secure
hypervisor and managing guest guest
access rights are controlled by root so
it's clearly you can actually enforce
those policies and through the root if
for any reason one of the operating
system is corrupted or or hacked or the
hypervisor or the root can actually
initialize reset reboot that particular
environment without affecting the rest
so if your ring the seeing miss behavior
so as an example if in this case guest
one says you know what I'm it's been
hacked and was trying to access the
resources for guest - so it's okay I
figured out how to get access to guest -
so I'm going to start he's dropping or
trying to access the ethernet port or
memory a memory map of dks2 the moment
that access happens there is an
exception to the route the guest one is
trying to attempt to reach - guess - now
if it happens offer sometimes but there
may be a bug in the software or
sometimes the intention
so at that point you can actually have
rules to say okay know that if there is
repeating access to guess - something's
wrong with guessed one so I thought
either report it or even initialize it
so that mechanism is available to
control a very good alternative way to
and force poly security policies for
your environment at the hardware level
so you can as I mentioned handle up to
255 you haven't seen that many but
that's the that as far as the r6
Mitchell r6 instruction set 255 is the
number of number of guests you can
support so you could decide that certain
interrupts can actually be directed to
the guest you know what I want to give
USB control to guess 3 or Ethernet is
shared so let's move that to route or
Ethernet forest you know needs to be
shared so to create a proxy to guess 7
that can actually decide who to pass it
to so many flavors of managing this the
most important thing is that there is a
lot of at least you can actually
implement a lot of hardware support to
to reduce the overhead associated with
context switching and that's critical
for many of these applications next
thing I was going to mention and these
are by the way the capabilities that
that is available through mips open r6
so if you want to create your solution
for next generation products it's
available now you don't have to create
that working group to do it it won't
take you years or months compared to
other icers that still in this infancy
that's a big thing to notice this is
been there for two three decades and we
compact those three decades into a few
months and make it available to you with
other you open use open your open source
solutions the lot of work still being
done but here you can get get get off
the ground
run
next item is the what we refer to as MSA
so it's actually the Cindy engine that
it's also a part of the r6
extension this example of what we have
done at MIPS wave computing but this is
just an example of a CPU that is it's
got I'm not sure which core is this but
regardless of that I'm going to cover
the those sections and focus just on a
cindy portion simply ISM is actually a
an engine that sits next to the other
execution units like the or al use and
other functions and its intent is to do
DSP functions floating-point functions
or any other type of mathematical
functions or by a new function but in a
context of a dot product or a vector
type of product so in you know you could
design your cindy to alert this desired
size and this particular example is 128
bit white cindy we have roughly i think
some 150 instructions just for the cindy
meaning that you can do dot products mac
multiply accumulate functions so it's
pretty useful for running let's say
tensorflow cafe or any of these
algorithms it's not necessarily doesn't
compete with dedicated hardware for AI
but if you're doing learning for example
there's floating-point engine that's
there as well so you could literally
design your next generation AI based on
your particular version of cindy that is
tailored and can be efficiently scaled
for the application that you're going
after so as a 128-bit vector you could
make this similar to handle for example
16 8 bits 8 16 bits for 32 and to 64-bit
integer floating point boolean
or arithmetic operation so in this case
we have the instructions that are
defined for those so you can immediately
implement yours corresponding we have
actually 32 as well seem the registers
those are also hundred 28 bit white so
you can actually have let's say your
weights for your convolution 3x3 stored
in the register and actually don't have
to go back to memory all the time it
does give you a boost in improving some
of the algorithms for your application
so simply is quite useful for many of
the applications I think I'm gonna go
through showing you in this case how the
sim D operates and also in the context
of multi-threading so not all of you
guys are going to design a product that
has Cindy virtualization and
multi-threading what we have because we
normally develop general-purpose
processors but you could decide to do
that and this is one use case in this
particular case you have an application
flow there are some DSP algorithms so
from time to time you call it DSP
algorithm to run whether you have a
Sindhi or DSP engine that instruction
flow is in-line means that you have to
run the green instructions first before
you get to the red instruction flow you
can do multi software multi-threading
but effectively you have only a single
stream of execution with multi-threading
and simply now you can actually let's
say assign your DSP algorithms to be
dedicated to a thread and under scim the
engine are all quickly what should what
happens is that you're separating the
your normal instruction flow let's say
linux calling some ESP algorithm
knowledge and you you know you first of
all you separating it and then second is
that you actually utilizing different
hardware
the resources on the CPU and as a result
you immediately get enormous amount of
boost for your application you can
actually take it in a further and add an
additional threat now in this case no
you can actually get again more and more
throughput because you're taking
advantage of multi-threading and those
treads are assigned to a DSP algorithm
this may be one is a comm 3x3 one is a
comm seven by seven convolution seven by
seven or other algorithm so fill filter
or others but we have done a lot of
tests and and our customers also use it
where we see having to separate these
functions you can quickly get the IPC up
instruction per clock for that
particular area of the CPU so quite
effective method of boosting your your
application to put this is a use case
that's actually in production today it's
benefiting from number of things but one
of the main thing is is multi-threading
in this case you have a RF front-end you
got the baseband type processing and
then you have the control once you do
the baseband figure out the data and
then you actually have to pump the data
to the application processor one of the
challenges is that the in the 5g
environment its enormous amount of data
that has to come in and in order to
really handle this you know you end up
having a lot of processors in parallel
and we have demonstrated that actually
can reduce those number of processors to
a lot less by utilizing multi-threading
now in this case some of the course we
have for for example allow you to have
up to let's say nine threads so you
could effectively say you know what
thread 0 and those this interrupt and
you can actually start assigning threads
and what what does that mean is that
then
and you know when the data is available
for a specific flow you can instantly
response to it you don't have to push
and pop from stag you don't have to
flush the cache or other other means we
can actually jump to it and quickly
respond to there to that particular
context so it translates to executing
less number of instructions typically
when you do that you end up learning
less power so effectively you can do
more you can do more or you can do again
reduce the power so this is a true
example of it either through the data
path or the the control or the
interrupts so you can probably look on
the web and there's a lot more
information but my intent for this slide
is that to perhaps encouraged that there
is a lot you could do with this type of
context switching with with our
multi-threading tactic capability and
this for example in this case you have
four CPUs and nine threads that's one of
the use cases that we have four times
nine is literally 36 so you could have
at this system that you can have 36
different contexts in a small
environment ready to go you can assign
36 interrupts or 36 events if necessary
you can group them together so there is
a lot you could do and again that
becomes what's called a micro
architectural step that you have to take
and design a maybe slightly different
than design B and design C and that's
the approach mix has been taking for of
course generations and decades but now
we are making that available for you
guys to go and try that on your own and
actually is ready proven and and working
I think that's my last lighter thing
right so I'm gonna hand it back to Suraj
but some here to answer questions after
the presentation thank you for your time
very nice thank you
take out take that back to the
architects thank you